let's talk about the dollar liquidity
crisis what it mean by that and kind of
why you're concerned there's two dollar
little quincy crisis undergoing right
now okay
one is the BIS Bank of International
Settlements talked about the 15 trillion
dollars that foreigners have borrowed
the problem is is when you go into a
slowing economic cycle the world traders
in dollars world trade is currently
negative so therefore they don't have
the dollars to either pay back their
debts or service their debts and that
becomes a problem so that tends to drive
the dollar higher in periods of stress
because there's too much money there is
also a European banking system as
starved of dollars and because of
regulatory differences a dollar in the
United States and the dollar in Europe
is not the same thing they're not
fungible anymore so we had something
called the euro dollar market which is
the offshore dollar market and the
onshore funding market and they were
fungible so Deutsche Bank could have a
u.s. operation and fund its European
operations from it that stopped so
basically you got two different currency
systems which has led to the shortage of
dollars offshore which is why there's
this endless problem with the European
banking system is there's not enough
dollars to make that run because the
world actually runs on dollars and not
euros euros are a big part of it but the
dollar is what you actually need so if
you then think of the other part of this
equation is okay in a slowdown stuff
like the oil price Falls
well oil is another bunch of economies
that extract things out of the ground
and get paid a u.s. dollars for them you
get less dollars so you either have to
pump more oil and what's your price fall
which is basically the shell designs
you're doing right now the Saudis did it
in 2014 and the oil price went to 30
bucks and they're reticent to do it
again as basically the donors are
flooding the market with supply and to
get dollars that the supply-demand
imbalance leads to a lower exchange
price but they are trying to on an
aggregate basis get the same network
let's yes because let's say you have to
pay your costs of operational servicing
debt and other stuff is 10 dollars a
year well and if you get it all from oil
and you
income from oil is $40 a year well if
oil goes to all for 70%
you can't service your debts so the
incense was just sell more oils get the
fixed number of dollars in which is what
the shell guys are doing to try and pay
their debts because they're about to
blow up and it's the panic reaction
that's what it pumping more and more and
more because they're gonna blow up
because it goes from a premium price
play to a volume play exactly that
that's exactly the point it's a dollar
at any cost
yep so so that's the that is what's
going on in the rest of the world the
Bank of England and all the central
banks have said this is a huge problem
it is uncontrolled now and they don't
know what the outcomes are this is the
rise of the central bank digital
currency because they know they have to
do something transfer mechanisms are
broken there's a whole bunch of issues
of which I don't understand but the
central banks are clearly screaming that
we need to move away not from the dollar
as our standard because there is no
other alternative yet but even as a
mechanism so I don't even quite know
what this means yet but there's
something big come we'll talk about that
later so when you're sitting there on
shore there's a funding problem as well
okay because everyone's at the repo
borrowing money so it's telling you
there's funding issues everywhere right
now and there's not enough dollars in
the system even though the dollar is not
going up per se what you will see is it
starting to explode against the things
like the Brazilian realitor Collaros a
[ __ ] around all the weakest borrowers
have the problems first explain the repo
market they had is that fit in
the answer is I don't really know
because almost nobody knows we don't
know what's actually happening or we
don't know why it's happening we we
partly know why we partly know what but
we don't know the whole picture okay but
what I'm hearing is that again it's just
changed again because the narrative was
you know we've just supplied the Reaper
market it was fine there was a bit of
stress on a few hedge fund balance
sheets and prime brokers and it wasn't
stress they couldn't get the right
funding levels and and various issues
with the inversion of the curve creating
a shortness and some technical nature
but it's just come screaming back again
in the last few days with JP Morgan
think wow we don't want to say make it
look like it's a bad thing so we're
gonna borrow money next minute every
banks you know something's going on in
the repo markets again and I think there
is liquidity stress with some of these
larger hedge funds and I don't know
whether it's Citadel not meaning they're
necessarily losing money but I can't get
the money that they need to pay whether
it's it could be margin calls but it
could just be general funding
requirements yeah so again it doesn't
have to be catastrophic and I don't I'm
not I'm not one who buys into the
arguments that somebody's going under it
could be because Italy's showing some
stress it could be that there's a
problem deeper buried within and I don't
know what that well and I don't think
people understand how over leveraged
even hedge funds are right in terms of
some are some ants okay explain so if
you are somebody like and I'm just using
Citadel as an example because they're
not even really a hedge fund any longer
but they use huge amount of leverage to
basically create price liquidity because
they're a market maker and volatility in
price in equities and bonds in in
whatever it may be
they're the marginal provider of
liquidity basically and there's several
other firms like them they also keep in
line all the arbitrage because the banks
don't have capital to trade this stuff
anymore so they basically done on the
banks did which is arbitrage the parts
of the curve and keep the money markets
in line with the euro dollar mark and
the Fed Funds marking do all of this
stuff problem is is if suddenly their
funding was then huge funding for there
could be hundred tons levered
100 tonnes levered and they are that's
wild
yeah and they are I don't know how many
billion dollars Citadel is as a firm now
and again I'm not picking on Citadel
have no idea but these firms are have
huge leverage because they're very low
risk but all of these have that risk of
picking up nickels in front of a
steamroller that some things can go
wrong so there is a there is a problem
that could come from that they're very
smart people have the best systems in
the world the best risk management
they're exceptionally good at what they
do but if you just take the funding
level up by a few basis points screw it
all other ppl mm-hmm so it becomes a
real problem and then they start tipping
out risk yeah so your stress central
bank's a second ago and just mentioned
funding levels whatever we get close to
these periods they've got two tools
sister historically they can cut rates
and they can print more money we have
obviously seen them say that they're not
printing money in the quantitative
easing sense but balance sheets have
expanded four hundred billion or so over
the last couple of months we obviously
just saw the rate cut if you were
running one of these central banks let's
say the Federal Reserve for example what
do you do in order to at least mitigate
some of the damage that appears to be
coming if not say try this I am NOT a
buyer and belief that central banks are
evil okay I think they're a function of
the demographics that they've been
presented okay and yes they've made some
mistakes in terms of creating for
example part of the equity market bubble
I also think most of it was driven by
retirees or baby boomers trying to save
for retirement and and the corporate tax
break that allows corporations to buy
okay so I don't think it's just to do
with interest rates of low I think
interest rates are low for a reason
I think growth has been the lowest this
cycle than any other cycle in all
recorded history I think that as baby
boomers move into retirement if you
think the relative marginal buying of a
25 year old and a relative marginal
buying of a 60 year old a massively
difference so your marginal impact on
the economy Falls over time and what
happens is it tends to slow economic
growth and we're all over the world
and the closer you get to retirement or
into retirement
the less you spend so it has a big
lowering of growth so inflation Falls
with it yes and people say but my
inflation is not yes everyone's got a
different rate of inflation that's what
people have to realize you know yeah
okay explain that a little bit more
because I think when people hear that
they're like what the hell is he talking
about I did this I wrote about it in in
global macro investor and I said I took
a bunch of things and I said okay I'm
going to take a pair of jeans I remember
buying when I was a kid and I'm gonna
take the stereo that I bought around the
same time and I'm gonna compare like for
like and then I'm going to compare a
different rate of inflation for somebody
else and I worked out on a on a you know
hourly earnings adjusted basis just to
get a like for like some of the pair of
jeans that I bought at the time and
again I'm just gonna come right now
right about this seven or eight years
ago
proteins are button thumbs 30 quid in
the UK and they were expensive designer
jeans you're stylin I was you know I was
so pleased I begged my mum for these
jeans a pair of Levi's about 20 okay so
as a 50 cent premium - apparently vice
and Levi's worth the standard Jing so
you cut - when I wrote the article I
haven't checked this and the stereo that
I bought it was 100 pounds
now I lift a high-end stereo and look
behind quad stereo looks a couple of
other things anyway the point being is
basic goods with us exactly the same
price or less so the Levi's were
basically inflation adjusted less the
stereos were much less what was
interesting is the expensive jeans were
like five times more expensive or 10
times more expensive and the high-end
stereo was like 10 times more expensive
so and what I'm showing there was that
if you were slightly wealthier your rate
of inflation was about 15% or so on I
calculated well the CPI of the same
period would have been about like two
novel three so different people now if I
you're saying different people is really
you're different you and I would be
different because we buy different types
of goods and those different types of
goods ash
Caressa pensions and our relative our
fixed cost basis that is the important
matter within this so health care is a
huge proportion of some people's CPI
right it's not a massive proportion of
my CPI but it's a huge proportion of
somebody else and so that's why when
they see inflation it's enormous for
them when they see kids school inflation
University inflation why University
inflation why because we have the second
biggest generation of people all going
to university at the same time of course
there's going to be inflation they drove
it you know so different people have
different inflation rates and so I think
the notion the notion of a CPI is wrong
and I think you know the people who hate
the Fed for hiding the numbers I think
it's because everybody has a different
CPI so one back to if you're sitting
there near Jerome Powell what do you do
so go to zero do we go to negative do we
look print a bunch of money there's a
fair argument that whatever they do
makes no difference now I have a feeling
that they will have to intervene and
support the pension system at the end of
this come a little closer than my sorry
I think they're going to have to support
the pension system at the end of this so
there is a lot of monetary printing to
come and it's a natural consequence of
the aging population and the promise is
given to it now just to clarify this is
rate cuts to zero plus the money
printing or are those two things
separate I don't think they have a
choice but to cut to zero everybody else
in the world is zero so Don Trump is
right you know it's it's an anomaly and
it's pointless so cut it to zero no it's
not going to cause a stock market bubble
because we're in the middle of something
much bigger much more important so the
issue is then what happens right and the
only answer that we currently have in a
system that we currently are given is
fiscal stimulus funded by government by
central bank there is no other answer
and this gets us into if that money
printing occurs how does it get injected
into this gets a long story of how we
gets a Bitcoin McCarron yeah I'm
dropping breadcrumbs the hole where I
can